[Music]
it's our dreams for Disney movies to
come true
you won't believe how similar some of
our favorite Disney characters are to
real people wait until number one to see
how toys stories real-life version of
Sid turned a villain into a hero if this
is your first time visiting our channel
don't forget to subscribe to the things
and please give this video a big thumbs
up here are 25 Disney characters as real
people hiro hamada from big hero 6 hiro
hamada was disney's first japanese
protagonist jen who was a filipino
artist and cosplayer
was shocked to see a disney character
that looked exactly like him he embraced
the resemblance and added a hand styled
wig and even placed black tea leaves
between his front teeth to create the
same gap-toothed look Moana from Moana
Micaela looks like the real-life
Polynesian princess Moana so much so she
might legally change her name Michaela
dressed up as the lovable Disney
character and posted her photos online
she instantly received a slew of
comments and young fans are now
convinced that Moana is actually real
Ursula from The Little Mermaid ukrainian
judge ala Bundoora
created quite the storm when her photo
was posted on twitter vendera's tall
white hairdo and signature purple Ursula
makeup make it seem like the sea witch
has returned but instead of the sea
she's ruling the court slashed from
Zootopia it's not common that an
animated sloth would resemble a real
person in this case zootopia's
international popularity has resulted in
a hilarious picture of a Taiwanese girl
who looks almost exactly like flash the
goofy smile makes these two almost
identical despite their difference in
species Elsa from frozen and a face from
Florida looks so much like Elsa we can't
let it go the resemblance is so uncanny
that faith went to her prom dressed as
Elsa since then faith earns a living as
a model and works as an Elsa look-alike
Russell from up up surprised audiences
for its depth and story and character
featuring themes about life love and
loss Russell the optimistic Boy Scout is
the comedic relief we needed for an
otherwise more serious movie we are so
happy that this adorable character has a
real-life look-alike film from Hercules
two Disney characters resemblance to a
real person as planned this is
definitely the case for Hercules his
mentor Phil the lockers ease Phil with
smiling round facial features and
receding hairline looks exactly like
Danny DeVito who is the voice behind the
character Pocahontas
from Pocahontas yerkovich Danan became
famous for his artwork depicting
realistic versions of Disney Princesses
the project has made this Australian
artist an internet sensation and his
portraits really do turn our favorite
recognizable Disney characters such as
Pocahontas into real people Anna from
frozen Lexy grace Carlson turned her
cosplay success into a business called
Frost
sisters guessing up as Anna Carlson
works had children's parties bringing
the frozen princess to life she's also
known for cosplay as Princess Leia
poison ivy and Rapunzel vultures from
jungle book when jungle book was
released in 1967 film producers had
hoped to include a cameo of the world's
most famous band The Beatles
unfortunately rumor has it that John
Lennon was willing to appear but refused
to perform in the movie nevertheless the
Beatles are the vultures of real-life
look-alikes Tinkerbell from Peter Pan
Margaret Carrie definitely served as the
inspiration for Tinkerbell
Tinkerbell became more prominent in
Peter Pan after she was chosen as an
icon for the theme park Carrie loved
being recognized as the real-life
version of the Disney fairy scar from
The Lion King you may know Jason Momoa
for his role as Khal Drogo on Game of
Thrones but is there someone else he
remind you of Momoa has a distinctive
mark through his left eyebrow that only
adds to the unmistakable resemblance he
bares to scar the villain in the Lion
King king from Cinderella starring in
several movies and TV shows Wilford
Brimley is most known for his work in
commercials
was there something recognizable about
that round face white hair and iconic
mustache maybe that's because Brimley is
the real-life version of the king and
cinderella arnesto dela cruz from cocoa
audiences fell in love with Coco for its
authentic and respectful representation
of Mexican culture arnesto dela Cruz
resonated emotionally with audiences who
stantly connected him with real people
this makes sense as he was inspired by
three Mexican singers hey Jordan Pandey
Jorge in a great day and Vicente
Fernandez Jasmine from Aladdin many
children dream of growing up and
becoming the Disney princes and
princesses they loved it's kids for
Marlon member of xso Alain Kamiya Noel
this dream became a reality when she
dressed up as Aladdin's princes Jasmine
for Halloween
Noel really is Jasmine in real life boo
from Monsters Inc everyone fell in love
with the adorable boo from Monsters Inc
this little girl really is the character
as a real person the cheeky smile and
adorable pigtails almost make us hear
her shout Kitty
through the screen Carl from up Carl the
old man with a touching love story is
the character we all fell in love with
in up the dark framed glasses bulging
nose square face and warm smile makes it
impossible to deny that this man is Carl
as a real person linguini from
ratatouille as well-meaning as he is
awkward Linguini's aspirations allowed
him to take instruction from a culinary
mouse in ratatouille fans adored this
character including his real-life
look-alike a huge smile and head of
curls really makes it easy to mistake
this fan for linguini Ariel from The
Little Mermaid singer youtuber and
fashion designer Tracy Hines is so much
so the real-life Ariel from The Little
Mermaid that she recreated the fairy
tale for her wedding posing in photo
shoots on her big day it's like the
underwater redheaded princess has come
to life Prince Beauty and the Beast
Prince Adam the prince from Beauty and
the Beast has a twin in real life jeans
are cozy is the son of former french
President Nicolas Sarkozy not only does
Jean look exactly like the Prince but
they are both from France and both in a
position of power Captain Hook from
Peter Pan Russell Brand is definitely
the real person version of Captain Hook
from Peter Pan and he knows it
brand indulged in his resemblance to the
Disney villain as he took part in a
Disney Dream portrait series by Annie
Leibovitz John Smith from Pocahontas
though a member of the enemy Pocahontas
Bansal of John Smith he has a real-life
look-alike who is equally as attractive
with his strong jaw blue eyes and blond
hair Chris Hemsworth
exactly what john smith would look like
as a real person princess Kida from
Atlantis the lost Empire princess Kida
from Atlantis the lost Empire has a
stunning warrior look her style beauty
and long blond hair really helps
identify her real person counterpart
Cash's album with cannibal he picks her
in a similar look with face makeup and
her hair cascading down her back
Esmeralda from the Hunchback of Notre
Dom a teenager on Instagram posted
pictures that cost followers to take a
double take with her thick long dark
hair captivating green eyes and stunning
features the teen is identical to
Esmeralda from the Hunchback of Notre
Dom in or out of costume they look so
much alike Sid from Toy Story
will Poulter is Sid from Toy Story as a
real person and he took full advantage
of his fame and crazy resemblance to the
character involved in anti-bullying
campaigns Poulter dressed up as Sid for
Halloween and utilized the irony to
speak up against bullying and that's all
for the 25 disney characters as real
people make sure to LIKE the video and
subscribe to the channel to catch more
videos like this thanks for watching
[Music]